hey if you'd like to support the
production of more move university video
tutorials then please visit the support
move section on luffy anniversary comm
thank you and enjoy next up is LDL
low-density lipoprotein sometimes called
bad cholesterol may be another video on
that exactly why it's called bad
cholesterol anyway LDL is basically an
IDL remnant right we said the idea was a
precursor to LDL that's basically saying
that LDL is a remnant of ideal where as
it made its made in the blood right
because that's where the ideal is it
contains high concentrations of
cholesterol esters as we can see here
from this chart 37 to 38 percent of it
most of it is cholesterol esters so does
this make sense let's think about the
function okay what is the function the
function is to transport cholesterol to
peripheral tissues that's its main
function such a liberal cholesterol to
peripheral tissues
that's main function so does it make
sense that it would contain a high
concentration of cholesterol esters well
yeah all right that makes sense that
makes a lesson third in the world
because it's meant to transport
cholesterol you'll notice that almost
none of these they all have really tiny
concentrations of cholesterol that's
because cholesterol esters are the way
they're actually stored in these
particles that the cholesterol cannot
escape
okay now the LDL can actually be the LDL
particle can be endocytosed by the liver
and or peripheral tissues okay so that's
why I wrote here mainly its main
function is to take these cholesterol
these cholesterol molecules to
peripheral tissues what sort of binding
needs to have it for this to occur so in
order for the LDL to be taken up buying
cell a PO protein B 100 must bind the
LDL receptor and the LDL receptor is
actually pretty important and this
process of the binding and take being
endocytosed
we just
just another video so of VLDL about 60%
goes back to the liver which is a pretty
large proportion but about 40% goes to
the liver the cholesterol to these
peripheral tissues which is what we
think about mostly is the function of
this so when the cholesterol is taken up
by these other tissues the the
cholesterol can be used as part of the
membrane for that cell or for the cells
of that tissue it can be used as a
steroid precursor could use as a vitamin
d precursor all the things that we've
discussed previously right maintaining
membrane fluidity being a precursor to
steroids I'm not sure if we mentioned
vitamin D being it I'm not sure if we
mentioned cholesterol being a precursor
for vitamin D but it is so one of the
reasons LDL kind of gets a bad rep is
that if LDL is an excess of the need of
the peripheral tissues there are these
cells called scavenger cells scavenger
cells specifically they're actually
macrophages macrophages they'll
basically take up these LDLs in their
oxidized form okay oxidized form which
is often shown as ox LDL okay and they
become foam cells so when these
macrophages take up these LDL particles
they become foam cells and these things
can contribute to the development of a
thorough sclerotic plaques in blood
vessels which obstruct blood flow and
can be pretty dangerous and even lethal
okay
so let's pass see how that works in this
big diagram here so we left off with IDL
giving rise to LDL Veatch via the HTH
tgl enzyme so then we have LDL and then
what LDL can do is it of course can take
its its key function really is to take
the cholesterol esters to the peripheral
tissues which are noted here at the
bottom left
and the LDL receptor here in blue LDL
receptor LDL receptor it's actually
there too okay will bind to be 100 and
take up that be taken up into the cell
vo and it's a endocytosis so that's what
that arrow represents that little tiny
one there that's endocytosis into these
peripheral tissue cells and lysosomes
can then fuse with these vesicles and
these the LDL particle will be basically
hydrolyzed and broken down into all its
components and so we've got cholesterol
as well as the proteins involved in that
in that particle that are now can be
used by that cell or by the cells of
those tissues and so basically now these
peripheral tissues have cholesterol that
they can use right and that's the idea
behind LDL okay now of course some of
the LDL can go back to the liver okay
but what can happen is that a lot of if
there's a lot of LDL on the blood and
it's not being taken up entirely by
these peripheral tissues what can happen
is that oxidants can kind of get a hold
of these LDL particles and oxidize them
to oxidized LDL particles so we have ox
LDL over here and these will be taken up
by macrophages and when the macrophages
go through and take up these oxidized
LDL s they become foam cells and these
foam cells if they build up in the
intima of the blood vessel which is a
layer of blood in the blood vessels this
can form plaques and blood vessels and
this can thicken the the wall of the
arteries which is basically what a fluro
sclerosis is and that's that's pretty
bad that can that's can call it obstruct
blood flow and of course blocking blood
flow is is very dangerous because
tissues need to get nutrients that
exists in in the blood so um this skin
is of course we would talk about Afro
sclerosis and hypercholesterolemia this
is kind of where that
we'll come and we'll talk more about
that later but I hope that video was
helpful in kind of explaining what's
going on with LDL thank you for watching
thanks for watching be sure to LIKE
comment subscribe and don't forget to
share the video of anyone who you think
might find it helpful thanks and happy
studying